COHEN'S OFF TO THE CLINK.
HOW DID THE MEDIA RESPOND?
TOO WHICH I SAY SO WHAT?
WE ALL KNEW THIS GUY WAS SHADY.
HE'S SO SHADY YOU COULD HOLD A
PICNIC UNDER HIM.
BUT THAT'S NOT ON TRUMP.
IT'S NOT AGAINST THE LAW TO HAVE
A DIRTY LAWYER.
OR TO HAVE A DIRTY LAWYER WHO
PAYS OFF WOMEN YOU SLEPT WITH.
IF YOU ARE A CONTRACTOR FROM
QUEENS IT'S MANNED STORY TO HAVE
ONE.
STEP ONE, SLEEP WITH A PORN
STAR, STEP 2, HIRE A LAWYER.
STEP 3, PAY HER OFF.
EVERY PRESIDENT HAS FRIEND WHO
DO THINGS FOR THEM THAT GET INTO
HOT WATER ONCE YOU ARE ELECTED.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO DO IS
GET MY SLIMY DIRT BALL FRIENDS
IN TROUBLE.
THAT'S WHY I'M ANNOUNCING TODAY
I WON'T RUNNING FROM 2020.
WHICH MEANS MORE TIME FOR
TRAVEL.
I WONDER HOW MY COLLEGE
ROOMMATES WILL REACT?
WE'LL SEE YOU SOON, LITTLE
BUDDY.
FACT IS, PAYOFFS ARE UNSEEMLY.
BUT THEY ARE NOT ILLEGAL.
EVEN MORE, TRUMP USED HIS OWN
MONEY UNLIKE THE CREEPS IN
CONGRESS WHO TAPPED OUR POCKETS
FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT PAYOFFS
WHICH IS WHY NANCY PELOSI AGREES
WITH ME TELLING THE MEDIA TO
SHUT THE F UP.
>> I WISH THE PRESS WOULD SPEND
MORE TIME ON WHAT WE NEED TO DO
HERE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE INSTEAD OF
MORNING, NOON AND NIGHT
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK WE WOULD HAVE MORE
VIEWERS AND READERS RATHER THAN
THIS ONGOING COVERAGE OF WHAT'S
CURRENT WITH THE PRESIDENT FROM
ONE WAY TO THE NEXT -- FROM ONE
DAY TO THE NEXT.
GREG: SLAP MY FACE WITH A TAPE
WORM.
SOMEONE HAS BEEN WATCHING MY
SHOW.
BUT IF NANCY GETS IT, SHE MUST
KNOW THIS COLLUSION CRAP IS
GOING NOWHERE.
REMEMBER WHEN IT WAS THE BIG
STORY?
NOW IT'S BANISHED LIKE A POT
BROWNIE AT GARY JOHNSON'S HOUSE.
NOBODY REMEMBERS GARY.
BUT THE MEDIA STILL KEEPS SAYING
WHAT ABOUT RUSSIA 57 DIDN'T
WAYS.
THEY ARE LIKE A TALKING BOTTLE
OF KETCHUP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: WE NEED BORDER
SECURITY, THE WALL IS A PART OF
BORDER SECURITY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE GOOD BORDER
SECURITY WITHOUT THE WALL.
>> THAT AM POLITICAL COMMENT.
BORDER SECURITY IS THE WAY TO
HONOR OUR RESPONSIBILITIES.
>> THE EXPERTS SAY YOU CAN DO
BORDER SECURITY WITHOUT A WALL
WHICH IS WASTEFUL AND DOESN'T
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP: IT TOTALLY
SOLVES THE PROBLEM.
GREG: THE MEDIA WENT NUTS, BUT I
LOVED IT.
HE TIME TRUMP ACTS LIKE TRUMP
THE MEDIA'S HAIR CATCHES FIRE.
YOU HAVE A NORMAL DISCUSSION
AMONG ADULTS AND THE MEDIA IS IN
A DITHER.
>> SHE SAID NO MAN-SPLAINING
HERE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
TRUMP'S POSTURE IN THAT ROOM?
WHAT DO YOU CALL THAT?
LOOK AT THAT.
HE WIDENED HIS LEGS AS FAR AS
POSSIBLE.
MAN STREAGD OR WHATEVER.
MAN-SPLAINING.
GREG: NONE OF THESE PEOPLE KNOW
PEOPLE WHO CALL THEM OUT ON
STUFF.
ARE THEY ALL LIVING IN THEIR
PARENTS' BASEMENT TALKING TO
THEIR COCKATOO?
NANCY WANTED THE DISCUSSION TO
BE DONE PRIVATELY.
AND POOR CHUCK.
EVERY DAY MORPHING INTO THE
PENGUIN FOR BATMAN.
MEANWHILE, THESE GUYS ARE
WORKING ON THEIR ACT FOR VEGAS.
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT TOE TO TOE
WITH HIS NEW FOE AND HE GOT
MAN-CHUCKED.
I LIKE IT BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE
MARTIAL ARTS.
DO I GET AN AMEN ON MY NEW NAME
OF MAN CHUCK.
I WAS GOING WITH.
>> THE MAN CHUCK WENT OVER WELL.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
GREG: THEY ARE THE LENNY AND
SQUIGGY OF CABLE NEWS.
I GET IT.
TRUMP MADE THEM THAT WAY.
BUT THIS GUY, MIKE PENCE.
AS SICK TO AS AN
AS SICK TO AS -N
AS SICK TO AS -- AS STOIC AS AN
EASTER ISLAND ATTRACTION.
HE REMINDS ME OF ME WHEN I WATCH
SARA SILVERMAN TELL A JOKE.
BUT HE'S JUST DOING HIS PART TO
REPRESENT TRUMP'S GRANDEST
PROMISE, A WALL.
HE BECAME AT THAT MOMENT A WALL.
AND TRUMP WAS SAYING IF WE DON'T
HAVE A WALL, I'M GOING TO SEND A
THOUSAND PENCES TO THE BORDER.
THEY WILL LOCK ARMS AND REMAIN
MOTIONLESS.
LOOK AT PENCE I DID WONDER WHAT
THE HELL WAS HE THINKING?
>> THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
>> GOD, "THE GREG GUTFELD SHOW"
IS SO FUNNY.
I WONDER WHAT THAT GUY IS LIKE.
BET HE'S AWESOME.
BET HE WOULD BE FUN TO GO
FISHING WITH.
CAN I BUY A BOAT?
I DON'T LIVE NEAR WATER.
DOESN'T MATTER.
>> YOU HAVE THE RIGHT HOUSE.
YOU HAVE THE SENATE.
>> WOULD GREGG MAKE FUN OF ME?
PRESIDENT TRUMP: I CAN'T GET IT
PASSED IN THE HOUSE IF I CAN'T
GET IT PASSED IN THE SENATE.
>> THE BOAT FIRST, THEN OR
SHOULD I MOVE THE BOAT IT'S A
BAD IDEA.
GREG ONLY LIKES ME BECAUSE I
HAVE A BOAT.
I HAVE A BOAT.
HE'S A BIG JERK WITH A BIG
STUPID FACE.
GREG: WHILE OTHERS SAW THIS AS
ANOTHER WEEK.
SOME SAID THINGS COULD YOU LOSE
YOUR JOB OVER.
>> IS THAT A PATRIOT SPEAKING OR
A WANNABE TAKE DAY DAY TORE'S
BUTT-BOY.
GREG: SHE CALLED THE SECRETARY
OF STATE A ANTI-GAY SLUR.
>> THE TERM IS OFFENSIVE AND I
APOLOGIZE TO EVERYONE,
ESPECIALLY THE LGBT COLLEAGUES.
IT WAS A MISTAKE.
MY FATHER WOULD HAVE FOUND IT
DISRESPECTFUL AND HE WOULD HAVE
TOLD ME, I WILL WORK HARD TO BE
BETTER.
GREG: WE SHOULD ACCEPT
APOLOGIES.
BUT PEOPLE LIKE MIKA DON'T
ACCEPT APOLOGIES.
IF I SAID IT I WOULD HAVE MORE
PITCHFORKS IN ME THAN THE HOME
DEPOT.
SHE IS THE DAUGHTER OF A
DIPLOMAT.
THE WORD THAT COMES TO HER MIND
ABOUT THE SECRETARY OF STATE IS
THAT WORD.
MEANING SHE'LL BE FINE.
SHE IS PROTECTED.
FOR TWO YEARS TRUMP HAS BEEN
ACCUSED OF SAYING AWFUL THINGS,
BUT NOTHING QUITE LIKE THAT.
MORNING JOE HAS TRULY BECOME A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM.
WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST, STOCK
MARKET GURU.
COMEDIAN CHRIS REID.
SHE'S BOLD, NATIONAL REVIEW
REPORTER KAT TIMPF.
NIAGARA FALLS IS HIS DRINKING
FOUNTAIN.
FORMER WWE SUPERSTAR, TYRUS.
ALL RIGHT.
HEATHER.
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE ON THAT WHOLE
WALL MEETING DONE IN PUBLIC.
>> I LOVED IT.
I COULDN'T STOP WATCHING.
ONE PART THAT WASN'T SHOWN IS
PELOSI SAID WE ARE GOING TO CALL
THIS A TRUMP SHUTDOWN.
AND UNDER HIS BREATH HE SAID I
WAS GOING TO CALL IT A PELOSI
SHUTDOWN.
CHUCKY SCHUMER SAID WILL YOU
PLEASE ACKNOWLEDGE THIS TIME YOU
TAKE CREDIT FOR THE SHUTDOWN
BECAUSE HE HAD TO TAKE CREDIT
FOR IT IN AUGUST.
HE SAID YOU KNOW WHAT, CHUCK,
I'LL TAKE CREDIT FOR IT.
SO THIS TIME AS LONG AS HE TAKES
CREDIT FOR IT CHUCK AND NANCY
ARE HAPPY.
GREG: THAT'S TRUMP'S MOTTO.
HE'LL TAKE THE HEAT.
IT CAN'T GET MUCH WORSE.
THE HEAT IS ALREADY HOT.
THANKS FOR DRESSING DOWN.
WERE YOU HELPING YOUR FRIENDS
MOVE BEFORE YOU GOT HERE?
ARE THOSE SWEAT PANTS?
>> THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE MY FIRST EVER BLACK
JEANS IN LIFE.
NEXT TIME I'M GOING TO WEAR
ACTUAL TIGHTS.
GREGG  * MAYBE THAT'S MY GOAL TO
GET YOU INTO TIGHTS.
>> I HEARD THAT.
THAT WAS MY MIKA IMPRESSION.
GREG: WHAT KID YOU MAKE OF THE
WEEK?
>> WITH THAT MEETING, TRUMP
BAITS PEOPLE IN.
EVERYONE ACTS LIKE SHUTTING DOWN
THE GOVERNMENT SOUND BAD.
HE'S RUINING AMERICA.
HE KNOWS PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
FREAK OUT.
HE TREATS THEM LIKE A FAMILY
GOING TO DISNEY.
I'LL TURN THIS CAR AROUND.
AND THEY SAY NO, NO.
HE SAYS I WILL DO IT.
I'M GOING TO SHUT IT DOWN.
AND IT ALL WORKS OUT.
I DON'T MIND THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTTING DOWN, KAT.
I THINK YOU WOULD AGREE WITH ME.
KAT: I DO AGREE WITH YOU, GREG.
AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WHO
SUPPORTS TRUMP IS GOING TO CARE
EVEN FIT IS HIS SHUTDOWN AND HE
SAYS IT'S HIS SHUTDOWN.
IT'S FOR BORDER SECURITY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS HE RAN
ON.
THE REASON WHY A LOT OF PEOPLE
VOTED FOR HIM.
THEY ARE PROBABLY HAPPY TO SEE A
REPUBLICAN STANDING UP FOR
THINGS INSTEAD OF JUST CAVING
LIKE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS HAVE
IN THE PAST.
GREG: TYRUS?
TYRUS: FIRST OF ALL, I WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE IN WHERE SOME KUDOS
HERE.
THIS IS WHY THE MEDIA DIDN'T
WANT HER BACK.
THIS IS WHY.
SHE CAME TO WORK.
SHE CAME TO WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE MAKE
FICTITIOUS PEOPLE TO RUN AGAINST
HER.
BUT SHE DOESN'T HAVE THE VOTES.
THEY WERE TRYING TO CREATE HAVOC
BECAUSE SHE LITERALLY LIKE,
LET'S WORK WITH THE PRESIDENT.
SO KUDOS TO HER FOR THAT.
THIS IS SIMPLE WITH THE WALL.
IT AM CAMPAIGN PROMISE WHICH IS
A HUGE REELECTION CHIP.
THE THING HE HAS DONE WELL,
THOSE ARE THINGS IN HIS BAG,
WHEN REELECTION STARTS, I HAVE
DONE THIS, I HAVE DONE THIS.
HEALTHCARE, NOT.
IF HE HAS A VISUAL, TURN TO THE
SCREEN AND LOOK AT THE BEAUTIFUL
WALL WE BUILT.
IT'S HARD TO RUN AGAINST THAT.
GREG: YOU CAN'T RUN INTO IT.
>> IF LIGHTNING STRIKES AND THEY
WIN I GUARANTEE THE FIRST THING
THEY WILL DO IS PUT IN A WALL.
A STANDING APPARATUS TO DETER
MIGRANTS FROM GETTING OVER.
EVERYONE IS FOR THE WALL.
IT WILL GO CREDIT TO HIM AND
WILL LOCK IN HIS REELECTION.
GREG: I THINK TRUMP HAS IT BAD
WARD SAYING WE'LL BUILD THE WALL
AND MEXICO WILL PAY FOR IT.
I THINK MEXICO SHOULD BUILD THE